now a relationship I feel like all of us
have
with a great deal of Fascination but
because I think it feels so personal for
people is Jennifer Lopez and Ben Affleck
um you officiated their wedding yes okay
why
why do you think that we have such a
beautiful hope and aspiration for
refinding a love that we had that we got
away from and can you come back together
well I feel like we all have someone
that we consider The One That Got Away
yes and the one that got away is not
always the one we should get back with
just putting it out there right I just
in case we're going to break up some
marriages that's not the plan uh but but
I think there's this idea that if we had
something special
why did we lose it why did we give it
away why did we let it go but you have
to go on your individual journey of
growth to reunite again you don't just
reunite because you have the same old
feelings it's because you have new
growth the same old feelings will just
create the same old patterns and it will
lead to the same old result and so those
new ideas and I mean for me that moment
was just really special because getting
to see love up close is is really
beautiful uh I remember when when
Jennifer Lopez was walking down the
island
Ben's hands were shaking her lips were
quivering uh you saw a tear all down the
eye like it I was just watching those
micro moments these really mindful
present moments of love watching Love up
close is really beautiful and really
special
all right so I was I've been up you know
for days and nights just reading your
book and doing the workshops now I've
been single for seven years
and you uh were a monk in an ashram
taking in what you had to was a celibate
Journey for that time what should time
alone
teach us I would say that time alone
is really interesting because I think so
much of society is defined by time you
should be married by your 30 you have
kids by your this age do this by that
age we have all of these metrics and
Milestones and I think when you spend
time alone you get to redefine what's
important to you being with yourself is
so important I didn't realize that when
I was younger can you realize that when
you are younger it's hard I think so
many people feel that they lose
themselves in a relationship and the
truth is we didn't lose ourselves we
didn't know ourselves in the first place
and when you lose yourself in a
relationship you then have to find
yourself in solitude and so when you
find yourself when you're spending time
by yourself you actually discover who
you are and I get it that it's hard to
do it when you're younger but actually
it can be the best investment you make
even if it's against everything that
you're being pulled towards and all the
excitement of a relationship
I'm not saying you need to take three or
seven years alone right yeah you don't
need to go and live as a monk but the
idea of spending some time getting to
know yourself is probably the best
investment not just for your love life
your career your purpose your
friendships for any area of your life
well it's interesting that actually was
something I mean I had this whole thing
annotated like I can see you know I mean
I really I've been deep diving and you
mentioned the word purpose and you say
in the book something to the effect of
that you have to find your own purpose
you know you even have a little bit of a
calendar that I found very fascinating
with time off during the week of
togetherness time with other people time
with yourself yeah how do you have time
off while you're living with someone and
in a marriage or a serious relationship
yeah I think what we're getting at here
is why would you take away from your
partner what makes them feel whole and
full if you want to be a partner his
purpose then you've got to deal with so
much more and not realize that sometimes
their friends group is the best source
of joy for them their family their work
so the calendar that you're talking
about is an encouragement you don't have
to live it as it says it in the book but
why do we give up our friends why do we
give up our Collective friends why do we
give up our family so this calendar
breaks down every week or every month or
at least every quarter spend time alone
even if you're in a relationship you
have to spend time with yourself
spend time with the person of course you
have a relationship with them spend time
with Collective friends that's really
good for bonding and having deeper
Connections in your community and then
make sure you spend time with your
individual friends as well all of those
relationships are a part of loving your
partner better and feeling more full in
how you love them I love this so much
all right now we have a surprise for our
audience
everyone in the audience is getting a
copy of my new book
so thank you as well thank you so much
all right up next we're gonna um speak
with comedian Phoebe Robinson and uh
we're gonna learn what she learned from
her recent breakup she also has an
imprint and a new book published through
it um this book is exceptional we'll be
right back
[Music]